good morning john i am about to tell you
a story that no one knows a story that
honestly i did not know until i looked
it up in my g-chat archives it's the
story of how you told me
about the most impactful idea
that we have ever had allow me to read
you the transcript of the chat that we
had on september 26th
2010. john okay here is my idea
i want to make a five-minute video that
covers the whole french revolution and
it is hilarious and it is fun to watch
and it has lots of visual aids no one in
education even treats it like it's
interesting but i mean they made a deal
in an indoor tennis court because the
king was a baby and locked the door to
their
meeting room it's like the single most
interesting moment in world history
except for when the prince of nepal
became a serial killer so
is that not a great idea me it is a
great idea
john okay i will do it and that really
is
how crash course was born except
that i left something out and i lied to
you a little bit john
and i want that video to be our entire
pitch to redacted and other venture
capitalists because we were pretty sure
this was something that we could do
and that would have a lot of impact but
we couldn't imagine
having the funding necessary to do it
without the support of traditional
venture capital and i don't doubt that
if crash course had had to take that
path it could have been successful i
just think that if we'd done that
a lot of it would be behind a paywall
right now but thanks to a lot of things
going right
including john you advocating for it
over and over again
in the face of me having terrible other
ideas
which this chat also includes some of we
have never had to take investment and
honestly that has been extremely
powerful for crash course because it's
meant
that we've always been focused on
keeping it free in that initial chat
john
you were talking about something that we
still talk about now we call it
lowering barriers to learning some of
those barriers are just pretending
for some reason like the french
revolution isn't dramatically
interesting like making it boring
is a completely unnecessary barrier but
one of many other barriers to learning
would be great educational video
that costs a lot of money for teachers
and students that is a barrier that we
are trying to prove
is unnecessary i'd be lying though if i
said that that wasn't really challenging
like some days i think maybe that
barrier is a necessary barrier i don't
know
every day how we're gonna make crash
course work it has required a lot of
weird thinking on both the
how do we make money if we're not gonna
charge for this
front and also a lot of thinking on that
how do we make this as inexpensively as
possible
which i think is important we need to
essentialize we need to figure out what
is the most important thing
for lowering those barriers and do no
more than that but in educational
content there are corners that you
cannot cut and there are also corners
that we kind of can but we just don't
want to we want to do more
we want to do it better we want to treat
our teams and our contractors better so
at crash course and complexly in general
we've had to be really creative over the
years with
how we make money with advertising and
taking grant money from any organization
that really understands our mission and
with sub-able and then patreon and now
with a new thing that is ending today
the crash course coin
i'm very sorry if you didn't hear about
this sooner because this is the last day
but there are two coins
one is a hundred dollars and one is five
hundred dollars and each represents a
piece of our budget that will allow us
to reach either two thousand
or ten thousand students each one of
them is being minted at a small family
owned mint in arkansas from hand etched
dies
and this has been so successful that
there will be a different 2022 coin
available next year but this is
literally the last day that you can get
the 2021 coins the 500
ones are probably sold out by the time
this video goes up but maybe not this is
the very first one that was minted it
has 001 on it it's going to the first
person
who bought a 500 crash course coin and
you know who that person was
john it was our mom i thought i was
gonna fake cry and then i started to
real cry a little bit if you are
watching this and it is not friday june
25th i'm sorry the crash course coins
are no longer available but you can
please still support us on patreon more
than 10 years into this journey we are
so
excited to continue finding ways to
lower barriers to learning
john it was a great idea i'll see you on
tuesday